Have you ever said, I'm addicted to chocolate? Or, I just can't stop eating these chips? You might have meant it jokingly, but what if there's more than a kernel of truth to the idea that food can be addictive? We live in a nation awash with cheap, easy to get calories, mostly from highly processed convenience foods. One recent study found that two-thirds of the calories that kids and teens in the U.S. consume now come from all. ultra-processed foods like industrial breads and cereals, frozen meals, and packaged snacks. In recent years, some researchers have begun to argue that these foods are more than just tempting and tasty. In fact, they argue some types of food may actually be addictive, hijacking the reward pathways in our brain in a way similar to alcohol or cigarettes.
你有没有说过这样的话：我沉迷于巧克力？或者，我就是停不下来不吃这些薯片？你可能只是开玩笑，但如果“食物会让人上瘾”这个观点不只是捕风捉影，而是有更多的真相呢？我们生活在一个充斥着廉价、易得热量的国家，这些热量大部分来自高度加工的便捷食品。最近的一项研究发现，美国儿童和青少年摄入的热量中，有三分之二现在都来自各种超加工食品，比如工业面包和麦片、冷冻食品以及包装零食。近年来，一些研究人员开始争论说，这些食物不仅仅是诱人和美味。事实上，他们认为某些类型的食物实际上可能会让人上瘾，它们会劫持我们大脑中的奖赏通路，其方式类似于酒精或香烟。
So what's the scientific evidence that food addiction is real? And how can some foods trigger addiction? How does food addiction compare with other addictions, such as to cigarettes and alcohol? Are some people more likely to struggle with food addiction? And if so, what are the risk factors? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
那么，食物上瘾是真实的，这背后的科学证据是什么？某些食物又是如何引发成瘾的呢？食物成瘾与对香烟和酒精等其他成瘾有什么区别？有些人是不是更容易受食物成瘾的困扰？如果是这样，危险因素又有哪些？欢迎收听《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，主要探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。
My guest today is Dr. Ashley Gearhart, an associate professional. professor of psychology at the University of Michigan, where she runs the food and addiction science and treatment lab. Dr. Gerhardt studies the similarities between addictive and eating behaviors and how some foods may trigger addiction. She also investigates how food advertising drives eating behavior and the development of food preferences in infants. She has more than 100 academic publications and her research has been featured in media outlets including the Washington Post, The New York Times, NPR, and the Today Show. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Gearhart.
我今天的嘉宾是阿什利·吉尔哈特（Ashley Gearhart）博士，她是密歇根大学心理学副教授，并在该校运营食物、成瘾科学与治疗实验室。吉尔哈特博士主要研究成瘾行为与进食行为之间的相似性，以及某些食物如何引发成瘾。她还研究食物广告如何驱动进食行为，以及婴儿食物偏好的形成。她拥有100多篇学术出版物，她的研究曾在《华盛顿邮报》《纽约时报》、美国国家公共电台（NPR）和《今日秀》等媒体上亮相。非常感谢您今天加入我们的节目，吉尔哈特博士。
I'm thrilled to be here. Thank you for inviting me. Not all researchers agree that food can be addictive, but you and others argue that ultra-processed food in particular can be. So first of all, what is ultra-processed food, and what's the evidence that this type of food can be addictive? Ultra-processed foods is something we've really just started to understand and investigate recently. We're really thinking about these ultra-processed foods as these industrial creations that when you look at the back of the ingredient list, it looks more like a chemical science experiment than it does a food. You don't really recognize most of what goes into it. And what we're realizing is that the food industry has gotten really good at creating products that trigger our bliss points that make us want more and more and more. And they don't hit our satiety signals the way real food, fruits, vegetables,
我很高兴能来到这里。谢谢你邀请我。并非所有研究人员都同意食物会让人上瘾，但你和其他人认为，特别是超加工食品可以做到这一点。那么首先，什么是超加工食品？有什么证据表明这类食物会让人上瘾？超加工食品是我们最近才开始真正了解和调查的东西。我们真正把这些超加工食品看作是工业产物，当你查看配料表的背面时，它看起来更像是一个化学科学实验，而不是一种食物。里面绝大部分成分你其实都认不出来。我们意识到的是，食品工业已经变得非常擅长制造能够触发我们“极乐点”的产品，让我们渴望更多、更多、更多。而且它们不会像真正的食物（如水果、蔬菜）那样触及我们的饱腹感信号。
legumes, the sort of food we've been consuming for all of human history, these foods are so wildly different than those foods that some people have suggested that food is a wrong term for it, and we should instead call them chemical substances. So what's the difference between being addicted to food and just liking to indulge in treats more than you should? How can you tell if someone meets the threshold for addiction? I think that's such a great question, and it really gets at a little bit of a myth around addiction. I think people think you're either addicted or you're not. And in general, we really see that it looks like more of a dimension.
豆类，也就是我们人类历史上一直在食用的那种食物，这些食物与那些食物有着天壤之别，以至于有人建议说“食物”这个词用来称呼它们是错误的，我们应该把它们称为化学物质。那么，对食物上瘾与仅仅是比应有的程度更多地放纵自己吃零食，这两者之间有什么区别？你怎么知道某人是否达到了成瘾的临界点？我觉得这是一个非常棒的问题，它确实触及了围绕成瘾的一些迷思。我认为人们觉得要么你成瘾了，要么你没有。总的来说，我们确实发现它看起来更像是一个维度。
Some people will drink alcohol and not have any issues and can completely moderate it. Some people have a tendency to sometimes binge drink or consume past what's good for their health, but they're not necessarily consuming in such a compulsive, out-of-control way that it's starting to really impair or distress them. When I started to do this work, I really thought, well, how do we tell whether somebody, you know, just kind of eating a bag of chips at the end of the day and it's just a stress reliever, like having a glass of wine or whether they really are showing an addictive profile. And so I took our diagnostic criteria that we have in the DSM to try and dissociate between social drinkers and somebody who's actually addicted to alcohol.
有些人会喝酒，但没有任何问题，并且完全能够适度饮酒。有些人有时会有豪饮的倾向，或者消费超过了对健康有益的程度，但他们不一定是以那种强迫性的、失控的方式在消费，以至于开始真正损害他们或让他们感到痛苦。当我开始做这项工作时，我真的在想，好吧，我们如何区分某人究竟是在一天结束时吃了一袋薯片，这只是一种缓解压力的方式，就像喝一杯葡萄酒一样，还是他们真的表现出了成瘾的特征。因此，我采用了我们在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）中拥有的诊断标准，试图区分社交饮酒者和真正对酒精上瘾的人。
And I've applied that to the intake of these really highly processed foods with unnatural levels of refined carbohydrates and fats. And so, you know, the hallmarks of addiction that I'm looking at, for are a loss of control over intake. You're continuing to use in the same way, even though it's causing you emotional problems or physical problems. You're having these intense cravings where it's just kind of occupying your mind. And it's starting to really impair or distress you in a way that other important things in your life, like your social engagements or your health or your ability to focus at work, are being negatively impacted. How widespread do you think food addiction is? Are there really
我把它应用到了摄入这些含有不自然水平的精制碳水化合物和脂肪的高度加工食品中。所以，你知道，我正在寻找的成瘾标志是对摄入失去控制。你继续以同样的方式使用，即使它正在给你带来情感问题或身体问题。你有这种强烈的渴望，它简直占据了你的头脑。它开始真正损害你或让你感到痛苦，以至于你生活中其他重要的事情，比如你的社交活动、你的健康或你在工作中的专注能力，都受到了负面影响。你认为食物上瘾有多普遍？真的有
research-based estimates of what percentage of people meet the criteria for it? Yes. So in 2009, we developed the Yale Food Addiction Scale when I was in my PhD program with my advisors, Will Corbin and Kelly Brownell. And we just took those diagnostic criteria for what was called substance dependence at the time and applied it to the intake of highly processed foods. And from that scale, we can kind of estimate a similar diagnostic profile for what would look like a clinical level of addictive pull to these foods. Recently, there's been a meta-analysis that kind of combines across, you know, a range of the studies that have been done to provide us with an estimate of how many people might be really
基于研究的估计，显示有多少比例的人符合其标准吗？是的。所以在2009年，当我在博士生项目期间与我的导师威尔·科尔宾（Will Corbin）和凯利·布劳内尔（Kelly Brownell）一起时，我们开发了耶鲁食物成瘾量表。我们只是采用了当时所谓的物质依赖的诊断标准，并将其应用于高度加工食品的摄入。通过这个量表，我们可以估计出一个类似的诊断特征，也就是对这些食物产生临床水平的成瘾吸引力的人数比例。最近，有一项荟萃分析结合了（你知道的）已经完成的一系列研究，为我们提供了一个估计，即到底有多少人可能真的
showing this kind of full-blown addictive pull. And the estimate's about 14% of adults. And that's shockingly similar to what we see with alcohol, another legal, easily accessible substance. About 90% of people drink, but probably about 12 to 14% of people actually show a sign of an addiction to it. One of the things that's really striking to me is that we also have a version of this scale for children. And a meta-analysis that came out in children in adolescence found that about 12% of children were showing signs of this clinical level of food addiction. That is, of course, way past what we would see with something like alcohol or cigarettes or cannabis because kids are
表现出这种全面的成瘾吸引力。估计大约有14%的成人。这与我们在酒精（另一种合法、容易获得的物质）上看到的数字惊人地相似。大约90%的人喝酒，但可能大约12%到14%的人实际上表现出了对酒精成瘾的迹象。让我感到非常震惊的一件事是，我们也有这个量表的儿童版本。一项针对儿童和青少年的荟萃分析发现，大约12%的儿童表现出了这种临床水平的食物成瘾迹象。当然，这远远超出了我们在酒精、香烟或大麻等东西上看到的水平，因为孩子们
not really getting exposed to those products until typically adolescence early adulthood. In contrast, as you mentioned, it starts to become a majority of the diet for kids, at least in the United States and in other westernized countries. You know, there was a study that came out, I think just last week that talked about how nobody should start drinking alcohol until the age of 40. And I'm just wondering, should we be doing something similar with processed foods? No processed foods until you're 40. Yeah, you know, we certainly know that the brain is vulnerable.
通常直到青春期或成年早期才会接触到这些产品。相比之下，正如你所提到的，对于孩子们来说，至少在美国和其他西方国家，它们开始成为饮食的主体。你知道，有一项研究，我想就在上周发布，谈到没有人应该在40岁之前开始喝酒。我只是在想，我们是否应该对加工食品做类似的事情？在你40岁之前不要吃加工食品。是的，你知道，我们当然知道大脑是脆弱的。
The younger you are when you're exposed to an addictive substance, the more likely you are to have problems. And to me, it's one of the big questions and concerns about this sort of research is that, you know, kids are being exposed to this and aggressively marketed to, especially children of color. are particularly being aggressively marketed to by the food industry. And so it's setting them up where this is one of the major sources of reward, sources of ways to cope. It's not just really about the calories. It starts to be about the hedonics, the pleasure, the emotion regulation from a very, very young age.
你接触成瘾物质时的年龄越小，你就越有可能出现问题。对我来说，这是关于这类研究的重大问题和担忧之一，那就是，孩子们正在接触这些东西，并且受到积极的营销，特别是少数族裔儿童。食品工业正特别积极地针对他们进行营销。因此，这让他们陷入这样一种境地：这是主要的奖赏来源之一，也是应对方式的来源之一。这不仅仅是关于热量。从非常非常小的时候开始，它就关乎享乐主义、快乐、情绪调节。
And, you know, we do see that children who are showing these signs of addiction and they're eating, they have higher body mass index, higher emotional overeating, they're less sensitive to their satiety signals. they have greater body fat percentages. So it would suggest that this is a group of children who are at risk. Now, I'm a mother of two young children, and I have to tell you, it's hard.
而且，你知道，我们确实看到，表现出这些成瘾迹象并在进食的儿童，他们的身体质量指数（BMI）更高，情绪性暴饮暴食更严重，对饱腹感信号的敏感度更低。他们的体脂百分比更高。因此，这表明这是一群处于危险中的儿童。现在，我是两个幼小孩子的母亲，我必须告诉你，这很艰难。
I know all of this, but we have an environment that is set up to make my job as a parent as hard as humanly possible when it comes to navigating what my child eat and what we eat as a family. And so I'm focused on how do we set up an food environment that encourages health over profits. So are people who are at risk for other addictions also at higher risk for food addiction? And for example, if you have a family history of alcohol or other substance use, might you be a candidate for food addiction? Yeah. So we actually just have a study recently coming out in this in the APA Journal, Psychology of Addicted Behaviors. And there we found that a family history of problematic alcohol intake was associated with a much more heightened risk.
我知道这一切，但我们的环境被设定为：当涉及到引导我的孩子吃什么以及我们全家吃什么时，它让我作为父母的工作变得极其困难。因此，我专注于我们如何建立一个鼓励健康而非利润的食物环境。那么，有其他成瘾风险的人，患食物成瘾的风险也更高吗？例如，如果你有酒精或其他物质使用的家族史，你可能会成为食物成瘾的候选人吗？是的。所以我们实际上最近在APA期刊《成瘾行为心理学》（Psychology of Addicted Behaviors）上发表了一项研究。我们在那里发现，有有问题的酒精摄入家族史与高得多的风险相关。
of food addiction. Actually, even it was a better predictor of food addiction and even having personal alcohol problems. So it would really suggest that if you have a family history of addiction, you look back and you can see even if it wasn't food, you had family members who were struggling with things like alcohol, that this might tell you that you might be at heightened risk when it comes to responding to our food environment in a way that's problematic. In this study, we found that the people who are showing this kind of compulsive, addictive pattern of intake with these highly processed foods were also at heightened risk for their own personal alcohol problems and smoking and vaping. So it would suggest that kind of there could be this cluster of, you know, addictive risk that's
患食物成瘾的风险。事实上，它甚至比拥有个人酒精问题更能预测食物成瘾。因此，这确实表明，如果你有成瘾家族史，你回顾过去就能发现，即使不是食物，你也有家人在与酒精等事情作斗争，这可能告诉你，在以有问题的方式对我们的食物环境做出反应时，你可能处于更高的风险中。在这项研究中，我们发现那些对这些高度加工食品表现出这种强迫性、成瘾性摄入模式的人，他们自己出现个人酒精问题、吸烟和电子烟的风险也更高。因此，这表明可能存在这样一群成瘾风险，
expressing itself across multiple substances. So I have to ask you a question about a particular food. I know you've talked about how processed foods can be addictive and that people don't tend to get addicted to carrots or peas or things like that. I mean, you can control how much of that you eat. But there's one thing that I think is delicious, which is homemade bread, like the best bread ever in the world. And I mean, I could eat that like every meal, two loaves. What's happening with something like that, which is not a processed food? You know, Kim, it actually is, I would consider a highly processed food. So right now the field is really struggling with what are the best terms. And ultra-processed has really
它在多种物质中表现出来。所以我不得不问你一个关于特定食物的问题。我知道你谈到过加工食品如何会让人上瘾，人们往往不会对胡萝卜、豌豆或类似的东西上瘾。我的意思是，你可以控制自己吃多少。但有一件事我认为非常美味，那就是自制面包，就像世界上最棒的面包一样。我的意思是，我每顿饭都能吃那个，两整条。像那样不是加工食品的东西，会发生什么情况呢？你知道，金，实际上它是的，我会认为它是一种高度加工食品。所以现在这个领域确实在为什么是最好的术语而苦恼。而超加工食品实际上
been focusing on the kind of industrial concoctions of these sorts of foods that we are already kind of designed and programmed to find, you know, that frozen pizza tasty and that, you know, cookie you pick up on your impulse buy at the gas station to be yummy. But I and my lab have really been focusing on highly processed foods. And how we define that is the inclusion of refined carbohydrates and or added fats. And so even though it's homemade, it's homemade from a processed ingredient, which is refined flour, refined carbohydrate. And when you combine that often with things like, you know, salts and there's often
一直专注于这类食物的工业调配物，我们本来就已经被设计和编程为发现，你知道，冷冻比萨是美味的，你在加油站随手买的那块饼干是好吃的。但我以及我的实验室一直专注于高度加工食品。我们对它的定义是包含了精制碳水化合物和/或添加脂肪。因此，尽管它是自制的，但它是用加工原料自制的，也就是精制面粉、精制碳水化合物。当你经常把它与诸如（你知道的）盐等东西结合起来时，通常还会有
fats and those breads as well, what you're doing is you're creating a product that delivers really reinforcing refined carbohydrates and fats and salts. to your body in a way where you can just devour it really rapidly. And often we add butter, right? So we're adding, you know, or some olive oil that we dip into it. And so we're amplifying it even further. And so when we compare that to something like, let's say, a bean or, you know, even a banana, the level of refined carbohydrates in that is a higher dose.
这些面包中也有脂肪，你正在做的是创造一种产品，它能将真正具有强化作用的精制碳水化合物、脂肪和盐输送到你的身体里，让你能够非常迅速地将其吞食。而且我们通常会加黄油，对吧？所以我们要添加，你知道，或者一些我们用来蘸着吃橄榄油。所以我们进一步放大了它。因此，当我们把它与豆子，甚至香蕉之类的东西进行比较时，其中的精制碳水化合物水平是更高的剂量。
And the speed in which we can eat it, and the speed in which it impacts, our gastrointestinal systems and gets into our blood systems is much more rapid. And when I think about how we've created addictive substances, it's really similar. Like, for example, there's nicotine in eggplants. There's nicotine and cauliflower. But nobody's getting addicted to eggplants and cauliflower to get their nicotine, right? It's about the kind of processed cigarettes, the processed tobacco leaves that you get that provides a dose of artificially high levels of nicotine at a really rapid dose.
我们吃它的速度，以及它影响我们的胃肠系统并进入血液系统的速度要快得多。当我想到我们是如何制造成瘾物质的时，它真的很相似。比如，茄子里有尼古丁。花椰菜里有尼古丁。但没有人为了获取尼古丁而对茄子和花椰菜上瘾，对吧？关键在于那种加工过的香烟、你买到的加工烟草叶，它能以非常迅速的剂量提供人工高水平的尼古丁。
And then when you get the industrialized ultra-processed version of the tobacco cigarette, it also has a bunch of additives in there, like sugar and cocoa and menthol and things that even further amplify it. And that's what I see with these foods, that it's really about our brain getting kind of hooked on really powerful, impactful, rewarding substances that can set you up to lose control. So if, in fact, food is addictive, I mean, let's say that somebody has a food addiction, if they're taken off of highly processed foods, is there a period of withdrawal? Are there symptoms similar to the withdrawal that you might feel from stopping cigarettes or
然后，当你得到烟草香烟的工业化超加工版本时，里面也有一堆添加剂，比如糖、可可、薄荷醇以及进一步放大它的东西。这就是我在这些食物中看到的情况，这实际上关乎我们的大脑被真正强大、具有影响力、有奖赏作用的物质所迷住，这些物质会让你陷入失控的境地。因此，如果食物确实会让人上瘾，我的意思是，假设某人有食物成瘾，如果他们戒掉高度加工食品，会有一段戒断期吗？是否会有类似于你戒烟或戒酒时可能感受到的戒断症状？
alcohol or a drug, another drug? Yeah, so my lab has actually found some evidence that this does occur. It's preliminary early evidence. I'd say we need some more experimental work. But when we've asked people who in the last year have given up highly processed foods have tried to cut down on it and ask them about their experiences, they've reported that they experience many of the classic signs of withdrawal that we see in other addictive drugs. Again, I think we hit on a little bit of a myth here that people often think of withdrawal from addictive drugs as really physical where you're vomiting and you're shaking and you're sweating. Well, if we think about withdrawal from cigarettes, it really doesn't look like that. It's more about
或者酒精或其他药物，另一种药物？是的，所以我的实验室实际上已经发现了一些证据，表明这种情况确实会发生。这是初步的早期证据。我想说我们需要更多的实验工作。但当我们询问在过去一年中放弃高度加工食品、试图减少食用量的人并询问他们的经历时，他们报告说，他们在其他成瘾药物中看到的许多戒断经典迹象，他们都体验到了。同样，我认为我们在这里碰到了一些迷思，人们通常认为对成瘾药物的戒断是非常身体化的，你会呕吐、发抖、出汗。好吧，如果我们想想戒烟，它实际上看起来并不像那样。它更多的是关于
irritability and agitation and cravings and you feel edgy. And that's really aversive and plays a role in people returning back to cigarette use. When we look at those same exact criteria when it comes to people trying to cut down on highly processed foods, they report those same things that they feel edgy, irritable, anxious. They have cravings that are challenging where they can't focus on other things. They feel down. They have kind of anhydonia. And they report that that's one of the biggest factors that lead them to go back to their highly processed foods.
易怒、焦虑、渴望，你会感到急躁不安。这确实具有厌恶性，并在人们恢复吸烟方面起着作用。当我们审视那些试图减少高度加工食品摄入的人时所表现出的完全相同的标准时，他们报告了同样的事情：他们感到急躁、易怒、焦虑。他们有难以应对的渴望，以至于无法专注于其他事情。他们感到沮丧。他们有一种类似快感缺乏的表现。他们报告说，这是导致他们回到高度加工食品的最大因素之一。
And one of the things that was striking to me when we did this research is we asked people to kind of identify what was the period after you cut down where it was the most intense. Those symptoms were hardest to deal with. And people said it was about three to five days after cutting down on the highly processed foods. They really felt like it was really challenging to manage. when we look at withdrawal from other addictive substances, it actually follows that same time course of about three to five days is when it really peaks. And then if you can stick with it, it starts to get
当我们进行这项研究时，让我感到震惊的一件事是，我们请人们确定在减少摄入后的一段时期是什么时候最为强烈。那些症状最难处理。人们说，是在减少高度加工食品摄入后的三到五天左右。他们真的觉得这很难控制。当我们审视对其他成瘾物质的戒断时，它实际上遵循了相同的时间进程，大约三到五天是它真正达到顶峰的时候。然后，如果你能坚持下去，它就会开始
better over time. And after about six weeks, you start to feel a lot better. I think one of the things, again, that's striking about it in the context of food is that we also looked at this and talked to parents about when they tried to cut down on their children's highly processed food intake. And the parent said, oh yes, my kids were more irritable. They were anxious. They would try and sneak food. They were acting out. They were so much harder to parent. And it was the worst about three to five days after we tried to cut back. And so to me, this suggests that this might be a really important factor that's contributing to our really high failure rates and being able to sustain dietary change that we're completely missing right now and we're not addressing. Are there treatments then that help people get over that hump? What would you say to somebody who's really trying to kick the habit? Yeah, so this is an area where we definitely need more scientific study. I feel like we're so in the spot right now where we're still really arguing about whether this is a real thing, that we've only started to pivot into what are the best ways to treat this. But there is some emerging evidence. So when we look at the behavioral side of things, we see that a lot of the intervention targets that we traditionally use and our addictive treatments also are really key with trying to get control of your food intake. And that's about, you know, being able to identify your emotions and developing healthier ways of regulating your emotions that doesn't rely on the
随着时间的推移而好转。大约六周后，你开始感觉好多了。我认为，在食物的背景下，再次让人感到震惊的一件事是，我们还研究了这一点，并与父母交谈，了解他们何时试图减少孩子的超加工食品摄入量。父母说，哦，是的，我的孩子们更容易生气了。他们很焦虑。他们会试图偷偷吃东西。他们行为不端。作为父母，带他们要困难得多。而且在我们试图减少摄入大约三到五天后，情况是最糟糕的。因此，在我看来，这表明这可能是一个非常重要的因素，它导致了我们非常高的失败率，并且无法维持我们在饮食上的改变，而这一点我们现在完全忽视了，也没有去解决。那么，有什么疗法可以帮助人们度过难关吗？你会对一个真正想戒除这个习惯的人说些什么？是的，所以这是一个我们绝对需要更多科学研究的领域。我觉得我们现在正处于这样一个阶段：我们仍然在争论这到底是不是真实存在的事情，以至于我们才刚刚开始转向什么是治疗它的最佳方法。但确实有一些新出现的证据。所以当我们看行为方面的事情时，我们看到我们在成瘾治疗中传统上使用的许多干预目标，对于试图控制你的食物摄入也是非常关键的。这大约是，你知道，能够识别你的情绪，并发展出更健康的调节情绪的方法，而不是依赖于
substance, whether that's alcohol or food or tobacco, helping people really identify what are their cues and triggers ahead of time. And that might be seeing an advertisement on TV or a certain time of day where you usually snack or a certain person, but you know, either makes you mad or is the person you usually go get your three o'clock coffee break donut with. Having more of a sense of your cues and your reactions can start to give you some of your power back. We're also seeing that some of the medications that we see are effective in treating substance use disorders like naltrexone and buproprin are also showing some evidence of being
物质，无论是酒精、食物还是烟草，帮助人们真正提前识别他们的线索和触发因素。这可能是看到电视上的广告、你通常吃零食的特定时间、或者某个特定的人，你知道的，要么让你生气，要么就是你通常和他一起去喝下午茶吃甜甜圈的人。对你的线索和反应有更多的感知，可以开始让你夺回一些主动权。我们还看到，一些用于治疗物质使用障碍有效的药物，如纳曲酮（naltrexone）和安非他酮（bupropion），也显示出一些证据，证明它们在暴饮暴食和成瘾性进食的背景下是有效的，这些都是可能有助于支持人们康复的药物因素。但我认为在相反的方面有一件挺有趣的事情，那就是在传统成瘾物质的领域里，我们真的开始考虑你正在吃的食物，以及这可能会如何决定你在康复过程中能否成功。因此，我们开始真正理解，当你真的很饿时，你实际上是处于热量剥夺状态。那些告诉你你需要热量的肠道激素，向大脑的奖赏中心发送了直接的讯息系统。它们说，嘿，你知道，注意点。我们需要一些奖赏。我们需要一些食物。我们需要一些
effective in the context of binge eating and addictive eating, that these are factors that medications that might help support people in their recovery. But one thing I think that is kind of interesting in the opposite side is that we're really starting to think about in the realm of traditional addictive substances about the food that you're eating and how that might set you up to be successful or not in your recovery. And so we're starting to really understand that when you're really hungry, you're actually calorically deprived. Those gut hormones that tell you you need calories, have a direct message system up to the reward centers of the brain. And they say, hey, you know, pay attention. We need some reward. We need some food. We need some
热量。我们需要一些线索。所以我们实际上看到，如果你真的很饿，它不仅可能使你对高度加工食品的线索更加脆弱和敏感，还会使你更容易受到诸如酒精、香烟和可卡因等传统成瘾物质的影响。让人真正专注于规律饮食，三餐，一两顿高质量食物的零食，摄入足够的蛋白质，稳定血糖，这不仅可能是恢复与这些高度加工食品关系的真正关键，也可能是一种被忽视的干预措施，我们可以将其用于其他成瘾物质的康复中。食物成瘾与厌食症或贪食症之间有什么关系吗？
calories. We need some cues. So we're actually seeing that if you're really hungry, it might not just make you more vulnerable and sensitive to highly processed food cues, but also make you more vulnerable to traditionally addictive substances like alcohol, cigarettes, and cocaine. And that having people really focus on eating regularly, three meals, one or two snacks of high-quality foods, getting enough protein, stabilizing that blood sugar, that might be not only really key in recovering in the context of your relationship with these highly processed foods, but also may be an underlooked intervention that we could use and the recovery from other addictive substances. Is there any relationship between food addiction and anorexia or bulimia?
是的。所以我们在这方面做过研究。在神经性贪食症的背景下，我们绝对看到了非常高的食物成瘾认同率。因此，一些研究估计，高达80%至90%患有神经性贪食症的人报告说，在他们与食物的关系中，体验到了成瘾和类似成瘾的特征。在某些方面，这其实并不令人惊讶，对吧？它们的共同标志都是失控。对于暴食症，我们看到大约50%的暴食症患者符合食物成瘾的表型，另外50%不符合。符合的50%更有可能认同成瘾机制，如强烈渴望、
Yeah. So we've done work on that. And we're definitely seeing in the context of bulimia nervosa really high endorsement rates of food addiction. So some studies have estimated that up to 80 to 90% of people who have bulimia nervosa report experiencing an addiction and addictive-like profile in their relationship with food. In some ways, that's really not surprising, right? They're both hallmarked by a loss of control. With binge eating disorder, we see a, it's maybe more about 50% of people with binge eating disorder meet for the food addiction, phenotype, and 50% dope. The 50% that do are more likely to endorse addictive mechanisms like intense cravings,
情绪失调、高度冲动，这些是我们认为在物质使用障碍中发挥重要作用的核心因素。神经性厌食症则是一个更令人费解的问题。它本应是完全相反的。但我们看到，特别是患有神经性厌食症暴食/清除亚型的个体，尽管他们没有吃大量的食物，但他们在主观上将其体验为失控的暴食。这群人也会认同成瘾性进食。我很奇怪，就像我们看到有些人有客观的暴食，他们客观地暴食很多食物，但有些人没有吃很多食物但将其体验为暴食一样，我们是否也在食物成瘾中看到了这一点，即有些人，你知道，他们吃的全部就是火鸡三明治和（你知道的）一袋薯片，然后他们说，哦，天哪，这真的算是一次成瘾性进食发作。因此，在厌食症的背景下，我们真的需要更多地了解它。我们确实看到，对食物成瘾的认同以及厌食症与更严重的临床表现和潜在更差的临床预后相关。但稍微转变一下话题，我认为我想明确的一件事是，很多人问过我，这难道没有包含在我们的诊断中吗？你知道，我们有暴食
emotion dysregulation, heightened impulsivity, those kind of core factors that we think of as playing a big role in substance use disorders. Anorexia nervose has been more of a perplexing one. It should be the complete opposite. it. But we see particularly individuals who have anorexia and nervosa binge purge subtype, where even though they're not eating large amounts of food, they subjectively experience it as a loss of control binge. That group of people will also endorse addictive eating. And I'm really curious that in the same way we see that some people have objective binge eating where they're
症。我们有贪食症。你知道，食物成瘾是什么？不就是那个吗。而我会说，事实并非如此。你知道，我认为当我们查看那些患病率估计值时，我们发现大约（正如我所提到的）约14%的成年人认同这种食物成瘾表型，而只有约2%的人认同暴食症，大约1%的人患有神经性贪食症。这意味着我们有大量的人认同与成瘾一致的有问题的进食的临床相关表型，而我们没有解决也没有治疗它。
objectively binging on lots of food, but some people aren't having a lot of food but experience it as a binge, whether we're also seeing that with food addiction, where some people, you know, all they eat is like a turkey sandwich and, you know, a bag of chips and they say, oh, man, that was really an addictive eating episode. So in the context of anorexia, we really need to understand it more. We do see that that endorsement of food addiction and anorexia is associated with a more severe clinical presentation and potentially a worse clinical prognosis. But just to pivot a little bit, I think one thing I want to make really clear is that a lot of people have asked me, well, isn't this already covered in our diagnoses? You know, we have binge eating
这些个体更有可能拥有较低的生活质量，全面拥有更高的心理病理学水平，并且更不可能对我们传统的减肥和进食失调治疗做出反应。因此，我认为我们真的需要照顾并帮助他们，即使他们的表现方式没有被我们更传统的进食失调诊断所捕捉到。我们在本播客中之前讨论过的一件事是体重污名化的问题。你是否担心，将食物和进食讨论为一种成瘾行为，可能会增加围绕体重和肥胖的污名化？
disorder. We have bulimia. You know, is food addiction? It's just that. And I would say that that really isn't the case. You know, I think when we look at those estimates of prevalence, we see that about, you know, as I mentioned, about 14% of adults are endorsing this food addiction phenotype, whereas only about 2% of people endorse binge eating disorder, about 1% have bulimia and herbosa. And that means we have tons of people who are endorsing a clinically relevant phenotype of problematic eating that's in line with addiction that we're not addressing and we're not treating.
绝对会。所以，我接受培训的机构是耶鲁大学的瑞德食物政策与肥胖中心（Rudd Center for Food Policy and Obesity）。那里有一个非常大的群体，丽贝卡·波尔（Rebecca Pohl）是领导者之一，专门关注体重污名化。所以这在我的培训中处于核心和显眼的位置。事实上，丽贝卡·波尔、我自己和其他人做过这样的研究，我们通过实验调查了我们的这个担忧，即如果我们把这些高度加工食品谈作是会让人上瘾的，我们是否会使一个本已遭到污名化的群体受到双重污名化？事实上，我们的研究发现，它要么是中立的，不会增加污名化，要么如果有的话，它可能会减少针对体重较高个体的污名化。
And those individuals are more likely to have lower qualities of life, to have higher psychopathology across the board, to be less likely to respond to. to our traditional treatments for weight loss and for disordered eating. And so I think we really need to kind of attend to them and help them, even if they're not presenting in a way that's captured by our more traditional eating disorder diagnoses. One thing that we've talked about on this podcast before is the problem of weight stigma. Do you worry that talking about food and eating as an addictive behavior might increase the stigma around weight and obesity?
因为现在，我们所处的阶段类似于我看到的过去很多成瘾所处的阶段，那就是它只关注（你知道的）意志力。你只需要多努力一点，热量进、热量出。而它忽略的是，这是一个真正的价值数十亿美元的产业，它正在利用其研发预算来专门设计这些高度加工食品，以触发你大脑中自然强烈水平的奖赏，其方式让你难以控制。并且，如果这触发了这种成瘾的、强迫性的吸引力，这不仅仅是成年的选择，真正是由于一个有毒的环境，在大力推销一种我们并不十分了解的危险食物物质。因此，这似乎确实在减少污名化以及减少“人们只是不够努力，这只关乎意志力”这种信念方面起到了一定作用。你对那些试图弄清楚如何喂养幼儿的父母有什么建议吗？我的意思是，你暗示了你自己作为一个父母也在苦苦挣扎。完全避免这些预包装的超加工食品会更好吗？
Absolutely. So the institute where I got trained was the Red Center for Food Policy and Obesity at Yale. And there was a really big group there, Rebecca Pohl as one of the leaders, really focusing on weight stigma. So it was front and center for me and my training. And so actually, Rebecca Pohl, myself and others have done work where we've actually experimentally investigated this concern that we had, that, you know, if we talk about these highly processed foods as addictive, are we doubly stigorous? and already stigmatized group. And actually, our research has found that it's either neutral and doesn't increase stigma or if anything, it might reduce stigma towards individuals with higher weight.
还是说如果你禁止孩子们在家里吃它们，他们就会更受诱惑跑出去吃，也许是在邻居家，或者当他们大一点时，他们只会过度补偿，因为我妈妈从来不让我吃这些东西？我想说，这是一个我们需要更多纵向研究的领域。我们在该领域几乎所有的研究实际上都是横断面的。因此，很长一段时间以来，父母们一直有这样一种观点，即如果你克制或限制你的孩子吃高度加工食品，你将导致他们随后发展出限制性进食失调。他们会在其他能买到地方暴饮暴食。但这种研究的一个局限性是（我曾经治疗过进食失调），父母会来找我，他们会说，从这个孩子出生的那一刻起，他们对这些高度加工食品就有着如此强烈的奖赏吸引力和驱动力，以至于他们会吃到呕吐的程度，你知道的。所以如果我不介入并试图（你知道的）帮助缓和或防止这种情况，他们就会生病。他们会对这些食物产生很大的问题。因此，我们也看到，那些可能容易对这些食物产生这种强烈奖赏驱动力的孩子，会促使父母试图介入并进行更多限制。现在，总的来说，我认为任何极端可能都不会是我们最终落脚的地方。我认为说，你知道，这是完全的，没有适度。这就是，你知道，随心所欲地和你的孩子们一起吃这些高度加工食品。你的家里没有任何指导方针，这并不好。而在另一个极端，如果它在家庭中变成了一种痴迷，你永远、永远、永远都不吃这些高度加工食品，这就是（你知道的）禁果，我认为这可能也不是很好。困难的部分在于，这可能是一个复杂的话题，需要一个折中的方案。而且对于每个家庭来说，这可能都会是一个有些独特的答案。所以在我们自己的家庭中，我尽量把它变成一种默认状态，即我们吃的大部分东西都是真正的食物，也就是实际的食物。但我们绝对会（你知道的）有吃冰棒的时候，或者我们会有周五
Because right now, we're at kind of where I see we've been with a lot of addictions in the past, which is that it's just a focus on, you know, willpower. You just have to try a little harder calories and calories out. And what it's ignoring is that there's a true. billion dollar industry that is using its research and development budget to specifically design these highly processed foods to trigger a naturally intense levels of reward in your brain and a way that makes it hard to manage. And that if this is triggering this addictive, compulsive pull, it's not just an adult choice, but really the result of a toxic
比萨之夜。但我尽量让它成为一种（你知道的）更少成为现状的东西。现在，这对我自己的家庭很管用。但我并不认为对任何人都有一个完美的答案。老实说，我认为我们需要对父母更友好一些，作为科学家，我们没有答案，他们需要自己去弄清楚什么对他们的家庭和孩子来说是最健康的。所以你写过，这是一个无法在个人选择层面上解决的问题，这正是我们刚刚谈到的。相反，我们需要围绕食物和食物广告进行更广泛的社会变革和监管，才能真正发挥作用。你认为需要做出哪些改变？
environment, really pushing a risky food substance. that we're not well-informed about. And so that seems to actually be somewhat helpful in reducing stigma and reducing the belief that people just aren't trying hard enough. And it's just a matter of willpower. Do you have any advice for parents who are trying to figure out how to feed their young children? I mean, you alluded to the fact that you are struggling as a parent yourself. Is it better to avoid these prepackaged ultra-process foods altogether?
是的，我认为当我们回顾成瘾的历史时，这对我们来说是如此清晰，你知道，当我们看烟草时，与过度摄入这些高度加工食品相关的饮食相关疾病，与烟草产品杀死的人数不相上下。这是一个同样巨大的公共卫生危机。我们确实在烟草身上看到，并不是（你知道的）我们开发了更好的治疗方法来帮助人们认识到烟草是会成瘾的或不健康的。而是我们真正关注了环境、政策以及诸如限制对儿童的广告、把自动售货机从你（你知道的）可以随便去买且没有年龄检查的地方搬走等事情。税收可以真正建立起经济因素，
or if you forbid kids to eat them at home, are they going to be more tempted to go out and get them, maybe at a neighbor's house, or when they're older, they'll just overcompensate for the fact that my mom never let me eat this stuff? I'd say this is an area where we need more longitudinal research. Almost all of our research in this area is really cross-sectional. And so for a long time, there's really been for parents this idea of, you know, if you restrain or restrict your child from having highly processed foods, that you're going to cause them to then develop a restrictive eating disorder. They'll binge in other places where they can get it. But one of the caveats to that sort of work, and I've been somebody who's treated eating disorders
促使人们远离这种物质，这些都是在改变我们高度加工食物环境的背景下被考虑过的因素。有些国家一直是这方面的先行者。智利在限制针对儿童的广告和这些食物的包装方面做出了非常巨大的改变，限制（你知道的），增加税收，并真正开展公众努力来改变我们对这些食物的态度和关系。英国很快将出台许多新政策。美国在这方面真的处于落后地位。我们真的不是这方面的领导者。好吧，我们算是超加工食品的先驱，不是吗？绝对是的。这就像我们在烟草方面的表现一样。我们是烟草产品最大的创造者和
before, is that parents will come into me and they will say from the moment this child was born, they have had such a strong reward pull and drive towards these highly processed foods that they'll eat them to the point where they'll throw up, you know. And so if I don't step in and try and, you know, help moderate that or prevent that, they will get sick. They will have such problems with these foods. And so we also see that kids who are maybe prone to this intense reward drive with these foods, it's eliciting parents to try and step in and restrict more. Now, in general, I think either extreme is probably not going to be where we land. I think saying, you know, it's full, there's no moderation. It's, you know, eat these highly processed foods
出口商。而且，（你知道的）我们成为这些超加工食品的领导者一点也不令人惊讶，因为（你知道的），从1980年到2007年，超加工食品最大的生产商和创造者是菲利普·莫里斯（Philip Morris）和雷诺（RJ Reynolds），也就是烟草巨头。他们使用相同的策略来营销这些食物，通常会创造其中的一些食物，比如酷爱（Kool-Aid），你知道，那是烟草巨头的一项创造，并将目标对准儿童，对准少数族裔，然后，你真的试图转移视线，把责任完全集中在个人责任上，作为对与他们的物质相关的消极公共卫生后果的回答。而且，资助科学家和政客真正站在他们这一边，而不是去思考
whenever and however you want with your kids. There's no kind of guidelines in your house is not great. On the other end, if it becomes an obsession in the family and you never, ever, ever eat these highly processed foods, it's, you know, the forbidden fruit, I think that's probably not great either. The hard part is it's probably one of those complex topics where it's a middle ground. and that for each family, it's probably going to be a somewhat unique answer. And so in my own family, I try and make it the default where the majority of what we're eating is real food, you know, actual food. But we'll absolutely, you know, have times where we eat popsicles or we'll have a Friday
无论何时、以何种方式给孩子吃都可以，在家里没有任何指导原则其实并不好。另一方面，如果这在家庭中演变成一种执念，你们永远、永远、永远不吃这些高度加工食品，你知道的，这就成了禁果，我认为这可能也不是什么好事。困难在于，这可能是一个需要折中的复杂话题，对于每个家庭来说，答案可能都有所不同。因此，在我自己的家庭中，我尽量让它成为一种默认状态，即我们吃的大多数都是真正的食物，也就是真正的食物。但我们绝对也会有吃冰棒的时候，或者在周五晚上吃披萨。
pizza night. But I try and make it kind of, you know, more of, you know, less of the status quo. Now, that's what works for my family. But I don't think that there is one perfect answer for anyone. And honestly, I think we need to be a lot kinder to parents, that as scientist, we don't have the answer and that they need to kind of figure out what is healthiest for their family and with their children. So you've written that this is an issue that can't be solved at the level of individual choices, which is kind of what we were just talking about. And that instead, we need broader societal changes and regulations around, food and food advertising to really make a difference. What are the changes that you think are needed?
但我尽量让它不那么流于常规。这就是适合我家庭的方式。但我认为对任何人来说都没有一个完美的答案。说实话，我觉得我们应该对父母更宽容一些，因为作为科学家，我们并没有现成的答案，他们需要自己去摸索出对他们的家庭和孩子最健康的方式。所以你曾写过，这个问题无法仅仅通过个人的选择来解决，这正是我们刚才讨论的。相反，我们需要更广泛的社会变革以及针对食品和食品广告的监管，才能真正带来改变。你认为需要做出哪些改变？
Yes, I think when we look at the history of addiction, this is so clear to us that, you know, when we look at tobacco, which diet-related disease related to excessive intake of these highly processed foods, is on par with killing the amount of people that tobacco products do. This is as big of a public health crisis. And we really saw that with tobacco, it wasn't that, you know, we developed better treatments to help people realize that tobacco was addictive or unhealthy. It was that we really focused on the environment and policies and things like restricting advertising to children, getting vending machines out of places where, you know, you could just go get it and there wasn't like an ID check. Taxation to really set it up where there's economic factors that
是的，我认为当我们回顾成瘾的历史时，这一点非常清晰，你知道的，当我们看烟草时，与饮食相关的疾病——因过度摄入这些高度加工食品而导致的疾病，其造成的死亡人数与烟草产品不相上下。这是一个同样巨大的公共卫生危机。我们在烟草身上确实看到，并不是说我们开发出了更好的疗法来帮助人们认识到烟草具有成瘾性或不健康。而是我们真正关注了环境、政策以及诸如限制对儿童的广告宣传、将自动售货机从那些你可以随便买到且不需要查验身份证的地方移走等措施。通过税收来设定经济因素，
nudge people away from this substance are all factors that have been considered in the context of changing our highly processed food environment. And there are countries that have been really frontrunners on this. Chile has made really huge changes about restricting advertising and packaging of these foods that are really targeting children, restricting, you know, increasing taxation and really doing public efforts to change our attitude and relationship to these foods. The UK has a lot of new policies coming on board soon. America's really at the back end of this. We've really not been the leaders in this. Well, we're kind of the pioneers of ultra-processed food, aren't we? Absolutely. And it's just like how we were with tobacco. We were the biggest creators and
从而引导人们远离这种物质，这些都是在改变我们高度加工食品环境的背景下被考虑的因素。有些国家在这方面走在了前列。智利在限制针对儿童的此类食品广告和包装、提高税收以及通过公众努力改变我们对这些食品的态度和关系方面做出了巨大的改变。英国很快也将实施许多新政策。美国在这方面确实落后了。我们一直没能成为这方面的领头羊。嗯，我们可以说是超加工食品的先驱，对吧？绝对是的。这就像我们对待烟草一样。我们是最大的制造者和
exporters of tobacco products. And, you know, it's really not surprising that we're the leaders with these ultra-processed foods because, you know, the biggest producers and creators of ultra-processed foods from 1980 to 2007 was Philip Morris and RJ Reynolds, Big Tobacco. They used the same playbook to market these foods, often create some of these foods like Kool-Aid, you know, that was a creation from Big Tobacco, and target children, target racial ethnic minorities, and then, you really try and deflect and focus solely on personal responsibility as the answer to the negative public health consequences associated with their substances. And, the funding of scientists and politicians to really be in their court rather than thinking about
烟草产品的出口商。你知道的，我们成为这些超加工食品的领头羊一点也不让人意外，因为从1980年到2007年，超加工食品最大的生产商和创造者正是菲利普莫里斯和雷诺烟草公司，也就是烟草巨头。他们用同样的剧本去营销这些食品，往往创造出一些这样的食品，比如酷爱饮料（Kool-Aid），你知道的，那是烟草巨头的创造，并以此为目标锁定儿童、少数族裔，然后极力推卸责任，将解决这些物质带来的负面公共卫生后果的唯一希望寄托在个人责任上。而且，通过资助科学家和政客让他们站在自己一边，而不是去思考
what's best for society. I mentioned earlier that not all researchers agree that food can be addictive. And in fact, you recently wrote a journal article in the form of a back and forth discussion with another scientist debating the point. What are the main areas of disagreement among researchers right now? And what research do you think needs to be done to fill the gaps in our knowledge? Oh, that's such an excellent question. And, you know, this is science where we need more attention and we need kind of more of a focus on it. It's definitely not an open and shut case. But I would say that, you know, there's starting to be more and more of a general consensus around whether people can show signs of addiction and they're eating. I mean, it's really clear when we think of what are the hallmarks of an addiction, that loss of control, those intense cravings, you know, continued use despite. negative consequences. If we think of tobacco, one of the biggest pieces of evidence was that,
对社会最好的是什么。我之前提到过，并非所有研究人员都认同食物具有成瘾性。事实上，您最近写了一篇期刊文章，以与其他科学家的辩论形式进行了一场来回讨论。目前研究人员之间的主要分歧领域有哪些？您认为需要进行哪些研究来填补我们知识上的空白？哦，这是一个非常好的问题。而且，你知道，这是科学，我们需要更多的关注，我们需要更多的关注。这绝对不是一个板上钉钉的定论。但我可以说，你知道，人们是否能在饮食中表现出成瘾迹象，正开始形成越来越多的普遍共识。我的意思是，当我们思考成瘾的标志是什么时，非常清楚，那就是失控、强烈的渴望，你知道，不顾一切地继续使用。负面影响。如果我们想到烟草，最大的证据之一就是，
you know, someone will be told you're going to die. You have emphysema. You have lung cancer. You have to stop smoking. And many people couldn't. We see that for a lot of people, they'll get a type 2 diabetes diagnosis. They'll have a heart attack. They'll have gastric bypass surgery to try and deal with health conditions and severe obesity. And arguably the majority of people are unable to kind of make sustainable changes and their intake of these highly processed foods. For many people, the craving, the pull, the desire for these highly processed foods is too great. And even though they know it's actually literally killing them, they are unable to change their behavioral patterns.
你知道，有人会告诉你，你会死的。你患有肺气肿。你患有肺癌。你必须戒烟。很多人做不到。我们发现，对于很多人来说，他们会被诊断出2型糖尿病。他们会心脏发作。他们将接受胃旁路手术，以试图应对健康状况和严重肥力。可以说，大多数人无法对这些高度加工食品的摄入做出可持续的改变。对许多人来说，对这些高度加工食品的渴望、吸引力和欲望太大了。尽管他们知道这实际上是在字面意义上害死他们，但他们却无法改变自己的行为模式。
So I think they're starting to be an understanding that, okay, those indicators of addiction and people's behavior seem to be there. But now the debate is really about what is the real. role of the food. And some people have said, you know, it's really not about the food. It's just about the act of eating, you know, kind of regardless of the food that you're consuming, because we can't identify a single kind of chemical agent that is addictive. And so I actually think that personally, that these highly processed foods are an essential ingredient in being able to trigger this addictive response. You know, when we look at scientifically, what are the foods that people consume in a
所以我认为人们开始理解，好吧，这些成瘾指标和人们的行为似乎都存在。但现在的争论实际上是关于食物的真正作用是什么。有些人说，你知道，这真的与食物无关。这只是关于吃这个动作，你知道，不管你吃的是什么食物，因为我们无法识别出一种具有成瘾性的单一化学成分。因此，我个人实际上认为，这些高度加工食品是触发这种成瘾反应必不可少的成分。你知道，从科学角度来看，人们消费的食物是什么？
compulsive, addictive loss of control manner? It's about 100% highly processed foods. You know, if people could binge on kale and bananas or strawberries and watermelon and get the same fix, they would, right? These are people that are desperate to change and they're unable to. Now I think it turns to what do we use as our benchmarks for a value? evaluating what foods may be addictive and how do we know. And I've been really focusing on, you know, what are the benchmarks we use with tobacco? Tobacco products are incredibly complex substances. They have thousands of chemicals in them. And we were able to say, you know, these tobacco products are addictive and nicotine is the addictive agent because of the benchmarks that
强迫性的、成瘾性的失控方式？大约100%是高度加工食品。你知道，如果人们可以狼吞虎咽地吃羽衣甘蓝、香蕉、草莓或西瓜并获得同样的满足感，他们会的，对吧？这些人迫切想要改变，却无能为力。现在我认为，这关乎我们用什么作为评估哪些食物可能成瘾以及我们如何知道的基准。我一直非常专注于，你知道，我们对烟草使用什么基准？烟草制品是极其复杂的物质。它们含有数千种化学物质。我们能够说，你知道，这些烟草制品会让人上瘾，而尼古丁是成瘾物质，因为
they were able to trigger compulsive use. They're highly reinforcing, meaning we'll work hard to get them. They change our mood. They impact our brain. And when we look at these highly processed foods, you know, they tick all those boxes. They actually trigger sugars and fats and highly processed foods trigger the same amount of dopamine release, which is kind of, you know, the most key neurotransmitter in addiction. They trigger the same amount of dopamine release in the brain as nicotine, as alcohol. And so when we think about whether they are as powerful, I would argue that they are. And so I think more research really needs to be focused on, you know, even in this podcast, we've said food addiction so many times. And that's what I called it. You know, we first started doing the research. It's clearly not all foods. It's clearly this subset of highly processed foods that are unnatural, highly refined, highly rewarding products. And that's what people get hooked on. We can't get people to eat enough fruits and vegetables and legumes and lean meats. Even when we spend, you know, millions of dollars. on public health campaigns to encourage them, whereas, you know, people are really struggling to get
它们能够引发强迫性使用。它们的强化作用很高，这意味着我们会努力去获取它们。它们改变我们的情绪。它们影响我们的大脑。当我们审视这些高度加工食品时，你会发现它们完全符合这些条件。它们实际上会触发糖和脂肪，而且高度加工食品会引发同等数量的多巴胺释放，这可以说是成瘾中最关键的神经递质。它们在大脑中引发的多巴胺释放量与尼古丁和酒精相同。因此，当我们考虑它们是否同样强大时，我认为它们是。因此，我认为需要将更多的研究集中在，你知道，甚至在这个播客中，我们已经说了好多次食物成瘾。这就是我所称呼的。你知道，我们刚开始做研究的时候。显然并非所有食物都是如此。显然，这是一部分不自然的、高度精制的、高回报的高度加工食品。这就是让人上瘾的东西。我们无法让人吃足够的水果、蔬菜、豆类和瘦肉。即使我们花了，你知道，数百万美元。用于公共卫生运动来鼓励他们，然而，你知道，人们真的在努力争取
a handle on their relationship with these foods, even in the face of really stark consequences. So are you saying the argument on the other side, the researchers who don't believe this is an addiction, is because you can't identify this one substance like nicotine? That's the main argument. And that eating is just so complex that it's so hard to tell. However, you know, people are dying. You know, this is now number two, maybe even number one, cause a preventable death in the United States is our relationship with these highly processed foods. And when I think about this, I also find that that idea that we've never, we did not identify tobacco as addictive because we were able to tell something about the chemical signature of nicotine.
在面对真正严峻的后果时，掌控自己与这些食物的关系。那么你是说另一方的争论，那些不认为这是一种成瘾的研究人员，是因为你无法识别出像尼古丁这样的单一物质？这是主要的论点。而且吃东西太复杂了，很难分辨。然而，你知道，人们正在死去。你知道，这现在是美国可预防死亡的第二大，甚至可能是第一大原因，那就是我们与这些高度加工食品的关系。当我想到这一点时，我也发现那种认为我们从未、我们没有将烟草识别为成瘾物质的想法，是因为我们能够通过尼古丁的化学特征来分辨某些东西。
As I mentioned, you know, nicotine exists in eggplants and cauliflower. Nicotine and, you know, a nicotine patch is not very addictive. If anything, it's a treatment. It's not just about whether it has the chemical in it, but about what is the dose in which it's delivered, how rapidly is it delivered to the system, and is it further amplified by additives? You know, we see with nicotine that the flavor additives, the taste, the sugar, the cocoa, the menthol starts to play a huge role in amplified.
正如我所提到的，你知道，茄子和花椰菜中都含有尼古丁。尼古丁，你知道，尼古丁贴片并不是很成瘾。如果有的话，它是一种治疗方法。这不仅关乎它是否含有该化学成分，还关乎输送的剂量、输送到系统中的速度，以及它是否通过添加剂进一步放大？你知道，我们在尼古丁中看到，风味添加剂、味道、糖、可可、薄荷醇开始在放大中发挥巨大作用。
flying that nicotine. Right now we're considering taking menthol out of cigarettes and that's thought to save millions of lives not due to any change in nicotine content, but because the menthol, that flavor, that cue becomes so potent and powerful in driving the addictive response. And so when I look at these foods, you know, I don't think carbohydrates in any form are addictive. I don't think fat in any form is addictive. But when I look at how it's delivered in these highly processed foods where it's refined made to be exceptionally potent, if you think of natural foods, fruits have sugar, nuts and meats have fat, and natural foods, carbs and fat don't come packaged together. You know, they don't, breast milk is probably our best example of, you know, carbohydrates and fat being delivered together
那尼古丁。目前我们正在考虑从香烟中去除薄荷醇，据认为这可以挽救数百万人的生命，这并不是因为尼古丁含量的任何变化，而是因为薄荷醇、这种风味、这种线索在推动成瘾反应方面变得如此强烈和强大。因此，当我看着这些食物时，你知道，我不认为任何形式的碳水化合物都会让人上瘾。我不认为任何形式的脂肪都会让人上瘾。但是，当我看到它如何在这些高度加工食品中输送时，它经过提炼，变得异常强大，如果你想想天然食物，水果含有糖，坚果和肉类含有脂肪，而天然食物中的碳水化合物和脂肪并没有包装在一起。你知道，没有，母乳可能是我们最好的例子，你知道，碳水化合物和脂肪被组合输送
because they're both really potent reward activators. When we think of our processed foods, the majority of them have fat and carbohydrates that are refined and then at levels that far surpass what we see and naturally occurring foods. I don't think our brain knows what to do with that. And I think if you have risk factors like a family history of addiction or trauma is a big one we're seeing or struggle with emotion regulation, then you are at heightened risk for being vulnerable to these foods. Well, Dr. Gerhardt, this has been fascinating. I really thank you for joining me today. My pleasure. Thank you so much for inviting me on. I really enjoyed it.
因为它们都是非常强大的奖励激活剂。当我们想到加工食品时，它们的大多数脂肪和碳水化合物都是经过提炼的，其水平远远超过我们在天然食物中所看到的。我认为我们的大脑不知道该拿它怎么办。而且我认为，如果你有家族成瘾史或创伤等风险因素——这是我们看到的一个大问题——或者难以进行情绪调节，那么你对这些食物的脆弱性风险就会增高。好吧，格哈德博士，这太迷人了。非常感谢您今天加入我。我的荣幸。非常感谢您邀请我参加。我真的很喜欢。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher 以及您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学对话》以前的节目。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以通过 speakingofpsychology@apa.org 给我们发电子邮件。本期《心理学对话》由莉·温纳曼 (Lee Wynerman) 制作。我们的音响剪辑师是克里斯·孔迪扬 (Chris Condyenne)。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯 (Kim Mills)。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。